[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
hey we're gonna do that go to
audio settings
just you know what
just do it like this you know what so
so what we're back you know
had some audio troubles
thank you all for joining the stream
uh melvina masterminds is a is a
non-profit that i that i started in in
chicago
i got this place in my old neighborhood
and i wanted to
create programming that wasn't there
when i was growing up now
uh we were supposed to open in 2010
no we weren't 2010 that was 10 years ago
2020 we were supposed to open
uh we also received a neighborhood
opportunity fund grant from the city of
chicago
uh and you have to do a lot of paperwork
we really it's chicago is really
serious about you gotta everything is is
tight except for our our parking
situation our parking meter
situation in chicago and if you're not
from chicago
look up chicago parking meters
privatization so you can get what i'm
talking about
yeah i'm not just letting i'm not
letting these local jokes
die if you not i'm not letting it it's
up to you
it's up to you to dig to see where i'm
coming from we're on the internet
already you know what i'm saying all
right
i'm gonna get blue for this
here welcome
you all uh we wanna
we wanna thank you and this show
this stream today we're gonna have
gaming no
well actually we're gonna have gaming
don't hey give me the uno cards
hey can i somebody grab me the uno cards
grab me these uno cards there we go got
gaming
boom okay got some uno cards you know
what it is
i got these on i never opened up a fresh
pack of uno cards
this is actually i've never been to one
opening it's a uh
these are this this is why nobody
trusted me to do it because it's a
it's a task that is it's not for the
it's not for the week you know
and it shouldn't be done
in public
these uno cards about to
play some solo uno we're about to play
some solo uno let's get back to the
here we go
all right we'll get into uno later let's
act like professionals here
i'm talking to myself everybody else is
doing their job
pretty well uh i wanna i wanna
really let's i'll do some new
you know what i'm i always wanted to do
a news show
no i didn't you had to do that every day
but today
i'm doing news i'm doing the news
let's let's get we'll start what's our
top story
for today
tennessee team accused of driving
a hundred six miles per hour
to get crickets to to feed his geckos
uh now he here's what i
i think
107 miles per hour you just get it
he had a suspended license already you
know what this is this is classic
this classic adhd right here
driving 107 miles per hour adhd people
like reckless behavior chasing dopamine
he's driving that fast to feed his
geckos he's hyper focused he needs to
make this happen
typical what else
reckless drive all that is all
poor planning
that's all it's all you know what's cool
about being able to change colors like
this
it kind of makes it so if you got
because i
kind of see it i have a little bit of
that that crust in my mouth but it don't
bother me as much
because i'm blue and green so if you're
like yo you got something in your mouth
be like well
look at you you you're monochromatic
and i'm all over you know hey
so i have adhd and i think about
what my life would have been like if i
knew earlier
if i knew if i knew then
what i know now how
would things have changed
for me and
so i started doing some digging just on
the
on the condition and on
the history of the meditation
you know hold up that's that's other
stuff and you know what i found out
i know ritalin ritalin
was named after the dude's wife
because he back then
if you were a chemist then you had a new
drug
you just you just gave it to your wife
because that was the closest person to
you try this
we we made this back in the lab see what
it do to you
who there's there had to be some depths
because of that
somebody research devs
from bad pills
a chemist's wife a handmaid's tale
uh what about a handmaid i want a
chemist a chemist's wife's tale
trying random pills like that one that
one gave me diarrhea for
26 days but uh
for for ritalin because her name was was
her name rita was it rita
her name was rita so he named it ritalin
and uh she reported back that she got
really dope at tennis
and then america said let's
let's use this forever we got something
and then
and then really got popular
so what does that have to do with melvin
mastermind
i don't know yet but with your
donations i can help figure it figure
that out you know
you gotta
leandro hansen
synthesize methylphenidate at siva's
labrador
like the vast majority decided to test
his discovery on the first person he
could find
rita she rapidly noticed the effects
tennis game got dope the molecule acts
quickly on the nervous system
and improves concentration
now i'm not on ritalin but if i wasn't
on something
this event would not have happened at
all it would have been uh if i'm like
this
now what do you think i'm like
without adderall it's insane
now moving on
uh i i don't want to just
lecture you guys i want i want you to
leave with something you could you could
use
in your real life
and and and just give you a new approach
so in this
pandemic time we've been all trying
different skills and
and new things and
i became a fitness
instructor i'm a fitness influencer now
a lot of people i lost a little weight
it was mostly
because i was drinking weight
but then you can then you don't eat dumb
food when you're out late drunk
but i did some other stuff too it wasn't
just only that
you gotta you gotta you gotta step it up
and so
i decided to put my program
on for people and so uh here we go with
that
hey this is hannibal birds welcome to my
new workout series called
moderate sweat which i get a little
sweat but
not so much so that you must eat but
enough that you feel like you did
something i'm an expert at that let's
get into it you know
okay let's go [ __ ] chips
yeah chips bread
[Music]
is a good part any workout any skilled
athlete can run backwards for upwards of
35 seconds so make sure you want to do
that if you want your lung capacity
performing at peak performance
all right going to step right out here
to my favorite spot
in the parking lot it just gets the
right amount of sun
to ripe freeze and i just love it here
look around
the air there's flowers it smells
perfect now look at here
okay you want to drop down then do five
push-ups with the worst form and speed
you can't you wanna i'm gonna leave you
there with that cliffhanger
and we're gonna come back to moderate
sweat
in a few minutes but uh but first
you know nate robinson had a tough
weekend
and and i don't really
listen listen here you know
listen here i
listen
he five nine and he wasn't really
fighting
so he lost the fight
people trying to clown nate and
everybody should thank nate
for getting knocked out and letting us
temporarily distract ourselves from the
horrors of the world
huh
temporarily distract ourselves
from the [ __ ] of the world what would
you be doing if nathan get knocked out
of you talking about nate
you got to fire off six nate tweets
nate nate nate nate
uh what would you be doing
now people get to get their jokes off
forget about a pandemic for a little bit
but that wouldn't be happening that's
pandemic entertainment
nate robinson maybe a maybe
maybe a mattresses sponsorship or
something
and if you are a mattress company uh
that is uh
riddled with white guilt
feel free to donate to melvina
masterminds you know we're here
if you're here if you're a company
currently drowning in in
in white guilt
we we do take those dollars
now what i won't do is
hand hold you throughout you have to
boost yourself
from within after that i'm just gonna
i'll just say that and we'll we'll do
good work with the money but i'm not
thank you so much for that you know real
thank you you come to
back when events happen again and you
want to come to an event
then we'll do that all right uh
let's check back in with uh with uh
moderate sweat hey let's get back here
to my new workout series
moderate sweat there we go okay here we
go
oh perfect great job okay
okay now come with me you're ready to
run into the woods
okay this is the let me jump jump
jogging oh let me just take a moment to
oh
wow check that out it's just oh it
smells
great
okay let me see all right let me uh
i wanna i want to do a take a quick
moment
and mention the the mouth tape here
because some of you are wondering what
that
is and
i've talked publicly about having asthma
and so now because of that
people reach out to me about all things
breathing
i get i get nebulizers
wait i find out i know all the newest
nebulizer technology
all like there's secret newsletters
asthma technologists
we're on a group text hey
check out this one hannibal that all the
new asthma oh this one is
fantastic you only got to use it once a
month
and so this lady she wrote me i opened
my dm
whoa and then she said hey you gotta uh
you gotta start
breathing through your nose more i wear
mouth tape when i sleep
because you're supposed to breathe
through your nose and i wanted to say
shut up that that makes no sense what
are you talking about breathing through
the nose
i don't believe you and then and then i
did a little research and it checked out
but since i you know i'm easily
distracted i did it for two days and
then forgot so last night
i slept with my i slept with the tape
for you know
slept with the tape on and
got to be honest
i feel really great today i think it
helped
i think it's legit all that that you
know you get to do yoga breathing for
eight hours when you ain't doing nothing
it's the best time instead of having to
listen to somebody be all
yoga and then your essence be aware of
your body
who can concentrate on breathing
when somebody's talking like a weirdo
that makes my blood pressure go up
so what better time to do your yoga
breathing
when everyone else around you has shut
the [ __ ] up
while you sleep so
that's what i think on that be sure to
you know
donate you know
go donate and
melvina master thanks to the
great books foundation also for for
their support
um we've partnered with them on
on a few different things great books
foundation
in chicago okay
what's our second story we gotta go
let's get into
our second story was that oh
a man what this guy did what
he did he
taiwanese man sells his playstation
after his wife found out
it wasn't an air purifier uh
and uh okay
he he had it uh
i feel like you know
why she wanted air purifier in the house
more than
the playstation also that
the fact that he was able to pull this
off is uh he's a genius
and she should support him he might be
become a game developer
or something else but that's the uh
that's the second lead story
in the news today
is uh there was this one
this and then
we did that it's a different version of
the other story that's the follow-up
there's nate and uh
oh they made a a strainer weed
called night night nate that was really
fast that was saturday today is tuesday
people people are just too fast out here
all right let's jump back into moderate
sweat
with hannibal burst okay where were we
around here
oh here's his uh it gets real crazy at
this part
you're ready to run into the woods
okay this is the let me jump jump
jogging oh let me just take a moment to
oh wow
check that out oh it smells this is in
chicago today
okay come on whoops
whoops hey buddy
hey oh oh whoa huh
was that oh wow can't believe
wow that happened right now
you you pizza let me say let me talk to
you for a minute
get angry huh what's going on um you got
a problem with me
wow it was an angry moment for me i i
was just here trying to
i wanted to just real quick i wanted to
just let y'all know this is a
really angry moment for me and i i
struggle
with whether i wanted to put this in the
edit or not
but after a long discussion with my team
and myself i decided it should go in
just to
because it was it was honest
that's the one thing you just tried to
destroy me right here huh let me tell
you one thing
if that ever huh
i never you know let's skip ahead let's
skip ahead
we got it on this jogging jogging and
then sometimes when you jog if you jog
for 10 seconds and you feel like you're
about to
just lose it all take a moment and
do you all hear that just to i want to
reiterate that
for my workout program if you are
jogging
for 10 seconds and you don't feel good
it's okay to stop and gather yourself
you're not an olympian
you can just take a seat don't
don't don't hurt yourself if you're not
feeling it
take a break you know
sit on a rock for a little bit yeah seat
on a rock
and just reflect reflect
life where you've been what you're doing
where you want to go
where you guys where you going next and
you know just think hey
i did three push-ups today maybe i'll do
four tomorrow all right and now and so
on and so forth
until i get to 10 push-ups and then i'll
stop for six months
and then once you got those thoughts you
give a blessing to the rock you go back
into the sacred parking lot in the
suburbs of chicago
as you step out here you just set an
intention
hey yeah
how you want to approach today and
you just you know get prepped
for your closer workout the lunge
so now now before we just i want to just
get into the
the lunge right away and just
you know overwhelm you all so we we did
is the uh
you know out
oh no out now
before we get into the mind you know
we go to go to melvina masterminds.org
donate if you can if not
it's all so good you know you know
everything ain't about donating this is
the long game anyways
maybe you can't donate now maybe you
won't just want to come to something
another time you know not about to press
you
donate every every
every
hey king basil's
he should donate
and kev kevin hart
give me a vinyl mastermind some of that
some of that ride along two money
give us some of that you know
help out man kev does some good work he
helps out
now this has been a hell of a
rollercoaster ride
uh i've had an amazing time
i i i think the mission
has has has really
it's been we got our point across
today's given tuesday he's both stuck
you gotta
you gotta give you know you gotta you
gotta just
you gotta just you gotta you
it you gotta you gotta you gotta
you gotta you gotta you gotta
you gotta you gotta you gotta you don't
maybe you won't hey wow
now maybe mel find out uh
do it what's up what huh yeah
all right back to our program
uh we're gonna get back into the
conclusion
of moderate sweat with hannibal burst
uh we actually i just got a text
huh i just got a text we just got picked
up
for check that out
just got picked up for
thirty six episodes on the civil
stallone network so
don't overthink the idea if you have an
idea of yours just
get it going and push it out there you
never know
what could happen let's take us back to
moderate sweat arms out
okay you with me and then you want to do
messy somersault boom wow you got that
lunge
hold up let me just because i know this
one is a tougher exercise
so i know let me just jump back real
quick
just so you all can get this and and
we'll probably
you know as as we develop the curriculum
at melvina masterminds we'll have
an array of fitness programs online
and in person when the fear and panic
subsides in in the in our country
and then justifiable okay now you lunge
like that right
you see that that was the lunge part one
lunge part two you see
except you know what i wanna pause
moderately sweaty moderate sweat
for for a second you know hold on
hold on cuz i
you know let me turn hey hey hey turn me
turn me normal color real quick this is
serious
how's joe biden breaking his foot 50
days before he's even in office huh
hey we knew you were old but you already
doing old stuff
before you even get in like
what is the what are the rules
we can't have that is it
we knew it was going to be common but
this is too fast
the foot it starts with the foot
it starts with the foot and the hip is
the foot and the hip in here
all right that's that my thing turn me
black
that's a good that's a nice turquoise
right there
you know i remember back in the day
back in the day when i used to do my in
2006
when i would do my i made my first
virtual gig appearance
yep it was in the aol chat room and i
said hey
what's going on here now it's just i'll
never forget the feeling
of putting my best out there
and you know all the emojis were coming
through
and it was just you know good time
entertaining people that i
would never meet and so this takes me
back to that day and i
i appreciate you all um
for doing it so that's you know after
that
sorry to get political it's not
political
is it politic is it is it
is it i mean
is it as kinda but
not not really you know
what do you i don't you think so i don't
know
so uh i know a lot of you
i've been i've been seeing the chat i
see the chat
if you're in the chat put a uh if you're
in the chat
put hashtag moderate sweat in the chat
if you're ready to see the series finale
of modern sweat
in the last 10 minutes since we talked
about it i got that deal
i decided this isn't the show for me and
so
what you're seeing right now is the one
and only episode
an exclusive
piece of video content only just one
it's a one-on-one
you know how many sopranos and the wires
they made
so many five seed nine seasons
yeah when you make so many kind of
devalues your product a little bit buddy
huh david simon huh
breaking bad folks you just kept on
going and going and going now with so
many
which one is the good one huh you know
which one is the good one with this
modern sweat just one episode december
1st you know what it is say
all my folks in kazakhstan
thank you for tuning in this morning
hello all right well let you know
101. this show ain't ain't many of these
it's just one
let's get back into it so let me yeah
this is the closing exercise
dope congrats all right let's keep going
all right let's take it back
here's the elevated one we're getting
into so this is important these lunges
like once once
you once you add these lunges to your
repertoire
everything is going to change for you
and not just in the fitness and physical
area you know everything you're going
you're going to feel it you're going to
feel it
you're going to feel your life you're
going to feel that energy
you'll feel the blood and once you lunge
once it's lunch when it's lunch time
when it's lunch time
you're gonna have more fun at lunch time
you know
lunch lunch time is my lunch time
lunch time lunch time is my lunch time
you know what i'm talking about
[Music]
lunchtime is my lunch time
so
let's pull them out
let's close them out
lunchtime in my lunch time your lunch is
what you wanna
get your lunch time it's lunch
time get it lunch lunch
time it's sort of like lunch time
you get it you got it whatever so shut
your leg like this
with the lunch and then you put it up
and then you go like that bow
lunge up you got it and then now okay
now you lunge like that right
you see that that was the lunge part one
lunge part two you see now you go
i'll pause it for y'all at home just in
case the time and you gotta get the
space
so i'll give y'all a ten count while you
uh
figure that out at home for do your
lunch lunch time
one two three four
five six seven eight
nine ten great
dope congrats all right let's keep going
all right now here's the here's the
elephant
you know what when i watched this back i
didn't really
i feel like i didn't
i didn't hype you up enough for
completing the lunch it was very
quick and transactional when i was dope
great job you killed that lunch huh
who did that you did that
well you want to lunge one time like
that right
and then okay this is the advanced
version
so if you're about to do this
let me let me because this is i can't be
in the corner for this it's very
important
if you about to do this if you're about
to do this
this lunch i'm going to take a
20 minute intermission so you can get
your couch
out of the if there's a couch in the
area if there's any
pets in the space that you're doing any
stools
ottomans if your
duck feeder is in the living room
any items like that if you're really
trying to participate
in this exercise at a high level
i need i need for you to i need for you
to move that and i'm gonna give you the
time real quick
let's give them a quick 20 beat just to
you know get the stuff right for that
space that's one
two three 4
5 6 7
8 9 10 11
12 13 perfect
so now that you got your couch moved you
can do this exercise let me uh
get out of the way so you can see what
you need to do and i'm here
if you need anything let's go do
arms out okay you're with me
and then you want to do
messy somersault boom you got that lunch
into messy somersault now you go
perfect hold up that was too fast
uh and uh
post your video of you doing the lunge
messy somersault
with hashtag moderate sweat posted on
twitter
or instagram or tick tock and
we'll we'll we'll look at the best and
we'll send you
about 50 dollars
about 50 hours or so
so let's see that okay glad you
now aren't you glad you glad you moved
your couch ain't [ __ ]
all right you ready we're gonna do
another one lunch
right okay and somersault
yeah boom see
see that
see look at that
that form right there right you see this
right here you see that angle there
that's where we that's where you kind of
wanna
you wanna mix it up so you wanna do when
you're doing these you wanna do one
perfect and then you wanna do one
this doesn't now this doesn't look like
orthodox the standard
form that one would do
but it's it's still raw
it's still dope and it still
will get you in the place that you need
to be as a
as an artist as a physical
specimen as a dreamer
as an achiever this is the form right
here
boom and so all right
let's jump back in
perfect perfect
we see now you're you're worried do you
feel like a warrior yeah you should you
should feel like a warrior
after that
i'm proud of you you know i've just
i'm i'm so proud of you
and and what and
you you've come along so far in a short
time
wait did i already say that in the video
yeah
i think you're worried all right now
let's
let's finish it up close it out me all
right
close it out okay here with me for
closing words
yup for the workout okay
what's that over there akia i love kids
yep all right facts let's close it out
just says it out closing words closing
words this is
you know if you wasn't listening
actively now you need to listen actively
if you wasn't listening actively before
everybody watching this while looking
down at their phone if they looking at
the computer you're doing it i need your
focus attention for the final part
i need i i need it
you know and just keep on pushing
if you do if you did five five again do
it three times
a day for five days and then you lunge
out side lunges before you go in the
house
close it out always leave the gym on a
make never miss
that's what it is and that's what it was
hey
blessings see you at the next episode
there's no more episodes that's 101.
that's is 101. that's the difference
between me and
the simpsons huh
right the simpsons is cool but it's like
weird they're always around
what about this rear and only one of
these
the news oh the news it just keeps on
coming thanks
news hey news
how about you have a category in the
news with
[ __ ] that i can actually do something
about
because some of it is just informations
cloud not my brain is already busy up
there
news how about news and actionable news
you know
because some of it this is
something you just filling up time
[ __ ] well
this has been this has been uh
a formative experience in my life you
know
i'ma give you a quick moment to
shazam this if you want
pretty wavy i like it a lot all right
and uh thank you for watching
if you can donate if you can't ain't no
there's no beef i really don't i don't
get
into it with it it's not like that
there's some non-profits out there
though
you donate one yeah
because you got to keep it going that's
how it's just that's just a great
process
so donate whether you can or not
break yours no that's not a good
you're right tone it down hey thanks for
watching
the information is here you see the
border down there
down here in the border
thank you to all the news that helped me
get here
you know this kid
ps4 dude
ritalin information
all that it's been it's been it's been a
wonderful time
uh i'm gonna end this stream
now uh and i'm about you know what i'm
about to do when i end the stream
because when i watch something cause i
have weird
obsessions and things that you know i
always hate don't you hate when people
like got that that one part when they
they like touching the camera that
little weird the
yeah i can't i can't really get with
that i guess being blue kind of
smooths that out a little bit but uh
oh yeah and i do i could do a fade out
actually oh yeah i do
fade out okay thanks y'all thanks for
listening thanks to
all of my team they helped me put this
together
everybody you know
solar man media thank you to arya
shaleek jenkins jenkins
kennedy white brian babylon
marcus price
and uh see y'all later
[Music]
peace
night